i think oftentimes we want people to be
this ideal individual yeah yeah so i
take the jesus approach right
unconditional love
thinking about when i was a sinner
thinking about when i was messed up
thinking about when i was on my way
absolutely to be drugged out to be
locked up to be dead right so i put
myself in the shoes of these young
brothers because i was once these young
brothers absolutely and if it wasn't for
a mentor who came in my life and gave me
the blueprint and the dna i wouldn't be
here
[Music]
i'm still here that's right living
inside this tent for 100 days from
november 20th to february 28th bringing
to you the issues and awareness that you
need to know about the violence on the
south side of chicago but also to raise
as much money as possible to build a
community center on this much needed
block called o block it's called o block
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs took the o in his name and
started calling it oh block we decided
we're going to keep the old but we're
going to change it to opportunity block
i want to thank foster network for
giving me the opportunity every day to
bring you rooftop revelations to share
with you my thoughts viewpoints and
opinions as it relates to what's going
on in chicago and across our great
country today i have with me a brother
that is doing fantastic phenomenal
awesome work with males with young black
boys he has a mentoring program his name
is bondale singleton and i want to
welcome him to our show and uh have him
talk to you about what's going on in
chicago with our young black boy so
vondel welcome man hey man thanks pastor
you know pastor was actually the first
person to give me the opportunity to
work within the community
and uh just over the years my motto was
to pay it forward absolutely is to
figure out a way because it doesn't
matter how successful we become
individually yes uh what determines our
success is how well we can make somebody
else successful absolutely and really
that's what mentorship has been about um
the innovation around mentorship so we
created a program called champs champ
stands for culturally helping and making
positive success and we believe that
every young person is born to win
absolutely every situation in life so
yeah education empowerment and exposure
those three e's are the basis of what we
do every single day and you're doing it
well man you know when i when every
people talk to me about mentoring i say
yeah we do a lot of mentoring we mentor
a lot of kids but the the best one that
i know at doing it
hands down is vinedale singleton and
what you do man how is it that you're
able to take these young boys especially
i want to talk specifically about the
ones who are on the edge when i talk
about the edge i'm talking about the
ones they just one step away
from making some really bad decisions
how is it that you take those young boys
and you redirect them and help them
change their lives we we know of some
that you really have help and uh so how
do you do that yeah so building
authentic relationships meeting them
where they are not judging them i think
oftentimes we want people to be this
ideal individual yeah yeah so i take the
jesus approach right unconditional love
thinking about when i was a sinner
thinking about when i was messed up
thinking about when i was on my way
absolutely to be drugged out to be
locked up to be dead right so i put
myself in the shoes of these young
brothers because i was once these young
brothers absolutely and if it wasn't for
a mentor who came in my life and gave me
the blueprint and the dna i wouldn't be
here absolutely yeah man so what do you
think uh we need to do uh with the
violence in chicago you know we we're
experiencing a lot of violence it's the
height of the violence since since the
90s really um what is it that we can do
to to fix this issue because some people
who are watching across america are
saying you know
all this violence in chicago what are
they doing about it and i want them to
know that listen there are some people
like you like myself really working hard
to get rid of this violence but what
from your point of view what can we do
more of i think we need to shine a light
on what works you know we don't have a
silver bullet yeah uh is one of the
approaches mentorship is one of the
approaches but everybody talk about
violence prevention but no one want to
talk about violence intervention and
prevention working together absolutely
so i want to do prevention before we
have to do an event exactly i want to
get the brothers before they don't need
it exactly so the younger we start
accessing you know families because we
know we're dealing with a lot of young
brothers who don't have a father in a
home so the only example they get is
from the block it's from the hood
absolutely so when we replace that and
we're consistent and we show up and
we're consistent and we show up and we
steadily come in right we replace these
negative images of what they know to be
a man especially a black man and so
essentially
what i believe needs to continue to
happen is the resources yeah um and
finding out best practices who are
getting the outcomes you know who who's
doing the outcomes and and and double
and triple down and 10x what they're
doing exactly because it's a blueprint
and it can be replicated it can be
duplicated but it has to be sustained
yeah that's what i tell people that that
we got to figure out ways that these uh
institutions that are working to have
the outcomes like like project hood and
chance mentoring we have to figure out
ways to get a resource even more so that
we can 10 exit
maximize it that's why we're trying to
build this center so we can just do
more work greater work
but man listen i am so excited about
what you're doing i know you've been
what are some of the things now that
you're doing with chance mentoring uh i
want some of the people to know and i
want to know how they go to your website
and check it out too absolutely so right
now chaps represent over 71 schools
across chicagoland area we're popping up
chapters across the united states
awesome um but the power in what we do
is power partnership you mentioned
project hood so we partner across
corporate inspectors
business specters schools churches
clinics hospitals whoever need us
wherever there is a black or brown boy
we want to be there yeah yeah and so we
get outreach from everywhere because
people realize like
okay let's simplify what's working this
is not rocket science stuff right we
know mentorship work we know doubling
down on trade certifications license
degrees whatever pathway we can create
whatever pipeline we can create to give
them opportunities to give them exposure
to have their brain cells grow in a
different way um we know it works it
worked with us yes absolutely and it
works with the brothers that we working
with every single day to keep working
and it keeps working so i think one of
the biggest things that i'm thinking
about now is over the past three years
we've grown 766
wow uh that's growth and enrollment
that's growth and finances so people are
getting their eyes on again what's
working and figuring out from a city
perspective from a state from a federal
perspective how do we do
this on a larger scale right right so
yeah we after a thousand but we want to
get ten thousand we wanna get a hundred
thousand we wanna get a million we wanna
get a billion exactly we wanna get all
of the world so it's just a few of them
that's out there doing bad but we got a
million brothers and we can get those
couple guys absolutely absolutely and
you know i think a lot of people don't
realize that they think it's just
everybody running bug wild all these
young boys but it's really just a ham
that we got to get our hands on yeah
well man thank you as always tell people
how do they uh
find out about champ's mentor yeah so
you can find out about champs mentoring
go to www.champsmentoring.com
or
champsmentoring.org and you can follow
us on social media at champs mentoring
absolutely listen you america you've
been great helping project hood and been
a blessing but if you're looking for
another organization to support and to
help out this is definitely one that i
that i believe in wholeheartedly
so many young black boys in chicago are
being blessed and helped as a result of
the mentoring that they do so
thank you so very much as always thank
you vandal thank you brother love you
man love you too keep up the good work
i'm proud of you as i always say god
bless you god bless america and until
tomorrow peace
you